ein Tag essen wie innen ist eine Serie
in der ich verschiedene Länder
kulinarisch bereise ohne Deutschland zu
verlassen ich koche selbst ich gehe
authentische Restaurants und heute ist
Japan dran nach Mexiko nach Ghana nach
Österreich reisen wir heute nach Japan
ich bin sehr gespannt was uns erwarten
wird zum Frühstück holen wir uns erstmal
einen Matcha Latte frühstücken wir wie
in Japan nicht ganz traditionell warum
erkläre ich gleich aber wir holen uns
einen Matscher und was Leckeres auf die
Hand
[Musik]
sollen wir uns schon mal was aussuchen
das sieht Bild aus sieht aus wie so ein
Hotdog aber statt einer Wurst ist so
eine Karamellcreme drinne ich möchte so
ein curry-party Matcha cream
beide Mann
ich freue mich wieder mal einen Tag
essen wie in Japan war natürlich lange
Zeiten Favorit den ich schon lange
machen wollte es gibt allerdings gerade
beim Frühstück einige Besonderheiten
mein traditionelles japanisches
Frühstück ist sehr sehr sehr
üppig es gibt dieses Frühstück kaum zu
bekommen in Deutschland das einzige
Hotel dass das Frühstück anbietet hat
uns nicht filmen lassen naja deshalb
sind wir hier und das ist quasi so die
New Wave Japan bleibt natürlich auch
nicht stehen so wir frühstücken
wahrscheinlich in Deutschland auch nicht
mehr wie vor 100 Jahren hier gibt es was
wir auch schon aus little Tokio kennen
von der Immermannstraße in Düsseldorf
verschiedener Backwaren dazu ein Matcha
ich freue mich schon auf die Vielfalt
weil japanische Backwaren sind
vielleicht nach französischen Backwaren
die besten der Welt wir haben hier zum
Beispiel einen Hotdog mit Karamell und
gesalzener Butter eine sehr sehr wilde
Kreation die man so bei einem deutschen
Bäcker auf jeden Fall nicht bekommen
würde ich wäre das Probieren ich habe
das Gefühl es wird sehr sehr lecker
schmeckt super stark die gesalzene
Butter ist einfach so üppig ist halt
pures Fett ne mit so einem weißen
Milchbrötchen das oben drauf sind wie so
kleine karamellpops ja so Kügelchen wie
so vom Joghurt mit der Ecke wieso
crunchen
das Harz das fühlt sich schon sehr
richtig an super geil
mit der Butter
getrunken
weißt du grünen daher kommt das schmeckt
so sehr erdig irgendwie aber auf jeden
Fall nicht verkehrt als nächstes haben
wir einen Matcha Creme Hörnchen und auch
diese Hörnchen sind glaube ich typisch
in Japan mit verschiedenen Sachen
gefüllt Matcha Creme wir sind hier eine
Matcha Café darf natürlich nicht fehlen
ich frage mich wie diese süße
Interpretation schmeckt für diejenigen
die mich am liebsten selbst kochen sehen
wir werden natürlich das Mittag und
Abendessen heute selbst zubereiten
allein schon wieder wie sich das hier
angekommen so ein bisschen zusammen das
ist so wollt und fluffig dieses Gebäck
rein
das hat auch schon wieder diese diese
Noten aber viel süßer und das Brot ist
ungeschlagen also japanisches Brot das
haben sie auf jeden Fall drauf sehr sehr
geil zwei süße probieren würde sagen wir
gehen rüber ins herzhafte was ich hier
habe ist ein Oktopus Bällchen vollkommen
absurd ich glaube bei einem deutschen
Wetter oktoberflächen geben
Lokalnachrichten stehen
warum geht's an dem Format neue Dinge
kennenlernen ich hätte niemals erwartet
wie das schmeckt wirklich probierst zu
erklären das ist komplett crazy jetzt
ist erwartet dieses Stichwort so
Berliner Pfannkuchen Krapfen ihr wisst
was ich meine das ist schon ganz gut
soweit der Teig ist recht ähnlich nur
dass das Ganze wirklich wie so eine
Kruste noch frittiert wurde ich habe
auch durch Octopus gebissen trotzdem
vielleicht durch die Soße hat man so
süße Elemente klingt komplett Banane
aber es ist richtig lecker es lohnt sich
offen zu sein weil ich hätte niemals
gedacht dass das so gut schmeckt einfach
mal Kopf ausschalten also ein sehr
abwechslungsreiches Frühstück wir haben
verschiedene Backwaren probiert die wir
sonst nie gegessen hätten interessanter
Mannschaft ist vielleicht nicht meine
Nummer eins für die Zukunft Brot fürs
Mittagessen ist gesichert ich freue mich
schon sehr darauf dass du zubereiten das
Frühstück war geil war abwechslungsreich
weiter geht's mit dem Mittagessen wir
haben nicht nur unser Brot sondern auch
alle weiteren Zutaten für einen Katze
Sando was so viel heißt wie ein Kotelett
Sandwich wir machen das Ganze heute mit
Hähnchenbrust die wir einmal panieren
natürlich mit Pankow damit richtig schön
knusprig wird das Öl steht schon bereit
aber wir brauchen auch noch einen
kleinen Salat für ein bisschen frische
und dafür haben wir drüben einen
kohlsalat bisschen Frühlingszwiebel die
ist das Ananas ich erklär's euch ja
sowieso gleich ich würde sagen wir
fangen an mit dem Salat erstmal alle
unsere Zutaten klein wir nehmen ein
Viertel von unserem Kohlkopf heute mit
japanischen Messer natürlich dieses
Viertel schneiden wir jetzt ganz fein
oder wir ziehen es einfach durch eine
Mandoline die das Ganze für uns
übernimmt aber hier muss man auch seine
Finger aufpassen
seid vorsichtig das geben wir einmal in
unsere Schüssel als nächstes schneiden
wir noch ein paar Frühlingszwiebeln dazu
ich schneide hier unten den Strunk
einmal ab auch die ziehen wir hier durch
du machst das hier richtig leicht heute
entspannter daran gemessen wie einfach
es ist eine Sache die eigentlich jeder
zu Hause nachmachen muss eine
Knoblauchzehe reiben wir noch dazu damit
das Ganze ein bisschen Punch bekommt
jetzt brauchen wir noch den Saft einer
Zitrone die reinigt erstmal ein bisschen
nicht halbieren wir vorsichtig in die
Hand jetzt noch Mayonnaise ordentlich
Mayonnaise ein bisschen Pfeffer dran ein
bisschen Salz und jetzt das Ganze einmal
schön verbinden während wir den Rest
machen kann das hier so ein bisschen
marinieren kümmern wir uns um unsere
Katze Soße dafür machen wir den Herd an
für einen Saucentopf drauf erhitzen
Ketchup rein Zucker welches da Soße und
außerdem und das Erhitzen wir jetzt so
lange bis unser Zucker schmilzt und
alles perfekt miteinander verbunden ist
der Salat ist fertig unsere Soße jetzt
auch das heißt wir kümmern uns um unser
Hähnchen zu dafür brauchen wir eine
panierstraße die besteht aus mehl Eier
mit einem Schuss Wasser und penkopf das
ganze bereite ich vor wird sich einmal
dafür ehrlich das fühlt sich so geil an
gerade das machen weil es so schnell
geht und ich halt schon weiß was nicht
erwartet am Ende dass ich das Gefühl
habe ich jetzt noch häufiger machen
bisschen Pfeffer dran überall weil wir
wollen ja auch überall Geschmack drin
haben und Salz kümmern wir uns ums
Hähnchen ich habe jetzt zwei
Hähnchenbrüste die werde ich einmal so
weit es geht aufklappen und ihr seht
vielleicht hier ist es viel flacher als
hier vorne
nimmt dafür ein schnitzelklopfer oder
einfach einen Topf wenn ihr keinen
schnitzelklopfer habt oder ihn nicht
findet so wie ich gerade Benutzer gerne
Frischhaltefolie oder Backpapier oder
was auch immer dazwischen und spielt er
dann Topf ab und
so jetzt Salzen wir von beiden Seiten
dann ist unser chicken auch schon bereit
für die panierstraße erster Schritt
normales Mehl einmal schön andrücken
eine nasse und eine trockene Hand mit
einem Seiten nächstes geht es in die
Eiermischung schön bedeckt und dann ins
grobe Pankow wir wollen so wenig wie
möglich vom chicken durchsehen deckt das
ganze drückt so ordentlich dran hier so
eine schöne einheitliche Panade haben
wow guckt euch das an auch mit Liebe
panieren dass das wichtigste unser Öl
ist auf Temperatur und wir legen vom
Körper weg das Chicken hinein das ist
jetzt frittieren bis es goldbraun wird
unser chicken ist ein bisschen frittiert
denn ist jetzt einmal wow ich glaube es
ist soweit eine wunderschöne Farbe es
ist echt schön geworden ich bin sehr
happy kommen wir nun zum Anrichten wir
nehmen uns unser schokopan das ist kein
normales Toastbrot erstmal es ist sehr
dick geschnitten riecht so wie
Milchbrötchen und das ist auch die
Besonderheit das ist ein Milchbrot eine
Seite bestreichen wir mit unserer Katze
Soße geil sind wir natürlich auch nicht
wir wollen eine Sensation im Mund haben
no sexuell jetzt kommt unser Katze oben
drauf
als nächstes unser Salat und nicht zu
viel drauf spamen eine Sache fehlt noch
Mayonnaise natürlich auf der Oberseite
verstreichen wir jetzt grünen wir
unseren König in das oben drauf wichtig
für die anrichtete wir essen natürlich
trotzdem alles ist das für ein letztes
Mal unser japanisches Messer zücken und
den Rand abschneiden
diese wunderschönen Schnittkanten ich
glaube ich muss euch nicht erzählen dass
wir das Essen ist halbieren wir das
Ganze noch einmal platzieren wir unsere
Sandwich mit der Schnittseite nach oben
fertig ist unser katzensammlung Leute
Ich sage euch eins ich bin wirklich
super ready dafür guck mal das Hähnchen
ist super schön saftig das Brot schmilzt
quasi unter meiner Berufung es kann nur
lecker sein guten Appetit
es ist so gut unglaublich das Brot ist
das einzige was man hier in Deutschland
nicht so einfach bekommt ist leider
super wichtig weil es so schön weich ist
Eric muss das auch essen unglaublich
lecker alles davon zu geil achte mal
bitte auch mal auf diese schöne
Zitrusnote von Kohl allein schon wie
sich das in der Hand anfühlt Alter
das krasse ist dass das auch cool
asiatisch schmeckt so dass das auf jeden
Fall aus Asien kommen muss großen
Respekt an Japan dafür boah ich wusste
dass ein Tag essen in Japan lecker sein
muss aber das hier ist ein echter und
das ist zu Hause die braucht keine
Friteuse
top warm machen drei Viertel der Hitze
Holzlöffel rein wenn es Bläschen gibt
reinlegen fertig vor allem mit Geduld
nicht 100 mal gucken einfach mal in Ruhe
lassen das esse ich aber sowas von jetzt
einfach nach meiner Lobeshymne wundert
euch glaube ich nicht dass wir uns noch
mehr davon zu bereiten es war unfassbar
lecker und ich sage euch eins das
Abendessen was wir auch wieder selbst
kochen wird glaube ich mindestens
genauso gut es geht los mit dem
Abendessen ihr seht der Topf ist schon
brennend heiß weil wir jetzt dort meine
Hackfleisch anbraten werden ich werde
das ein bisschen durchkneten erstmal und
dann wie so ein kleinen Teller daraus
formen damit wir eine schöne
Kontaktfläche haben gerösterung ab geht
die Posten jetzt sind wir hier so Hals
über Kopf rein gestartet was machen wir
überhaupt wir machen Rahmen selbst sie
kräftigen eine schmeckt unfassbar gut
und gerade in dieser Zeit wo viele Leute
krank sind ich weiß auch eine Woche voll
am Arsch nach Karneval ist es wirklich
das Beste was man kann so wir werden das
ganze
ordentliche Restaurant dran oder von der
anderen Seite braten ist auch schön
durch und dann brauchen wir alles andere
wir machen eine misorahmen meine
lieblingsrahmen ultra einfach ultra
schnell also wirklich ich finde man hat
Angst wenn man hört Rahmen es klingt so
aufwendig und fremd aber es geht so
schnell und die Zutaten sind auch echt
überschaubar deshalb bleibt dran dann
können wir das Ganze ein bisschen
zerkleinern einfach mit so einem
quetschgen das ist die offizielle
Bezeichnung von dem Werkzeug und weiter
schön durch Braten oh wie das Dampf ich
glaube noch nicht so sehr gedown gedacht
jetzt gerade Alter man sieht leider
nicht ganz so viel durch den ganzen
Abend Filme jetzt einmal raus alles was
sie jetzt gerade festklebt ist Geschmack
und den lösen wir mit der Feuchtigkeit
der Zwiebel
bisschen Erdnussöl dran einmal schön
andünsten und wir können zu gucken in
Echtzeit die sich hier vom Topfboden die
festen Bestandteile lösen zu unserer
Zwiebel bzw Schalotte geben wir ein
wenig geriebenen Knoblauch und
geriebenen Ingwer das riecht so lecker
direkt dieses Ingwer richtig in die
Augen die Schärfe wir geben jetzt das
Fleisch wieder hinzu oder als nächstes
kommt der Zucker dran ich will direkt
ein bisschen durch mit der nicht am
Boden anklebt und das was wir darin
haben ist jetzt wirklich schon so eine
richtige geschmacksformel ihr habt
vielleicht an der Seite gesehen ich habe
ein bisschen Sesam angeröstet den
verarbeite ich jetzt so einer passte im
Mörser einfach stoßen vielleicht ist
euch ja eine kleine Änderung hier im Set
aufgefallen falls ihr neugierig seid
dann schaut mal in der Videobeschreibung
vorbei ist nämlich eine Website verlinkt
ne können wir mal vorbei schauen so
sieht das ganze dann aus das geben wir
jetzt dazu in unseren Topf jetzt fügen
wir die Miso passt hinzu rote so
erhitzen das alles einmal schön durch da
bin ich mir vor geht direkt ab wenn das
alles schön verrührt und verbunden ist
können wir unsere Flüssigkeit hinzugeben
das hier ist Hühnerbrühe etwa 1,2 Liter
am Topfboden hat sich wieder so ein
bisschen was angesammelt was jetzt quasi
langsam rausköchelt es wird einfach nur
geil wirklich ich bin mir sicher diese
trübe Brühe die wir hier sehen macht für
mich eine richtig gute Rahmen aus und
das war so schnell dieses Ergebnis zu
erzielen ich bin mir sicher ein
Geschmacksintensität ist das hier kaum
zu überbieten und wir haben so schnell
selbst hinbekommen richtig nice unsere
Suppe ist gerade aufgekocht wir geben
shiitake Pilze hinein die waren
getrocknet habe ich für eine Stunde in
Wasser eingelegt und die geben jetzt den
letzten Schliff jetzt stehen wir auch
direkt runter wir wollen nicht dass sie
lange köchelt sondern halten quasi
einfach warm die Pilze sollte aber für
mindestens 15 Minuten noch drin bleiben
hier drüben und hier vorne sind bereits
die Toppings für unsere rahmensuppe die
Eier wollen wir natürlich im Rahmen ist
gerade fertig machen das heißt mit so
einem weichen inneren das Erziehen wir
ganz einfach indem wir sie nach dem
Kochen in ein Eisbad geben und die sind
dann genau im richtigen Moment bereit
für uns außerdem machen wir noch in
Butter geschwenkten Mais und
Lauchzwiebeln ganz fein geschnitten als
Topping dann sind wir auch schon fertig
und dann müssen wir nur noch die Nudeln
kochen wir geben unsere Brühe drauf
einfach so wie sie ist unsere Toppings
kommen dann auch alle noch zum Einsatz
next ab Frühlingszwiebel boah die ist so
schön frisch das Eiswasser der
buttermais wirklich geschmacksbombe sein
Vater vielleicht auch nicht ganz gesund
aber wen juckt das schon Nori Blätter
[Musik]
hier ist sie also meine selbstgemachte
Rahmen ich bin ganz ehrlich gerade mit
der Schüssel und so kann die sich
wirklich sehen lassen probieren wir das
allerwichtigste zuerst die berühmt ich
nehme einen Löffel
[Musik]
sehr sehr lecker fühlt sich fast ein
bisschen falsch an dass ihr jetzt gerade
ohne Stäbchen zu essen wunderbar al
dente geiler bist wirklich die Brühe die
haftet auch schon so richtig an
wir haben heute sehr sehr lecker
gegessen unfassbar lecker wirklich wir
haben festgestellt die japanische
Esskultur ist nicht so unrecht im Hype
jedes Gericht war auch seine Art und
Weise wirklich wirklich besonders
wirklich lecker und auf jeden Fall wert
ausprobiert zu werden deshalb kocht doch
vielleicht das ein oder andere nach
falls ja viel Spaß dabei ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns allerspätestens wenn wir
gemeinsam das nächste Land kulinarisch
bereisen davor ist hier ein für dich
vorgeschlagenes Video darunter kannst du
den Kanal abonnieren und guck mal auf
Blog vorbei ciao